hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
2017 was a bumper year for PlayStation
gamers with a heap of exclusives to play
neo gravity rush to horizon zero dawn
persona 5 Gran Turismo spot hidden
agenda Uncharted The Lost Legacy and so
many more 2018 is shaping up to be even
more crammed with video games only
available on the ps4 so prepare your
wallet for an almighty buttering and
plan your way through 2018 here's 9
PlayStation exclusives that will blow
your mind throughout 2018 let's start
with the game I'm personally
unbelievably hyped for days gone
originally penciled in for a Christmas
release this one completely vanished
from sight for a while but the glimpses
we've seen have shown what the magnitude
of the zombie apocalypse has risen to
the sheer number of free-cos on screen
at once is simply mesmerizing and I get
it our job is to fill the boots of
outlaw-biker Deacon st. John who's a bit
of a drifter and a nomad he's also a
bounty hunter - in this new world a
global pandemic has brought about these
mindless zombie like creatures referred
to as freaker's who would be best
described as degenerated human monsters
days gone is ultimately an
action-adventure survival horror game
with RPG elements with a day/night cycle
and weather system which impacts deacons
approach to each mission this could add
to the replay value of the game and a
sense of planning many open world titles
failed to achieve I'll link a video
breaking down 2 ways to approach the
same mission for a little more context
dayz gun is quite reminiscent of the
last of us with scavenging and crafting
different items like a Molotov and
there's plenty of guns to go around -
and of course my favorite thing are
those environmental kill animations days
gone is coming in 2018 as soon as the
official release date is announced I'll
put it in the comments below
once there was an explosion a bang which
set a planet spinning in this face death
stranding is an upcoming game from Metal
Gear Solid Master Mind Hideo Kojima
you've most probably seen some of the
star-studded cast with the likes of The
Walking Dead's Norman Reedus film
director Guillermo del Toro and
multi-talented actor extraordinaire Mads
Mikkelsen death stranding itself is
still a complete mystery to many of us
with every trailer release the story
looks even more complex than it did
before
even Mads Mikkelsen struggled to
understand the story when Kojima
explained it to him so what do we know
so far we know the game will be opened
world and include a multiplayer feature
in addition to the core single-player
campaign which of course will be lengthy
so far we've seen what looks like human
experimentation in the shape of babies
in jars some people believe the babies
are clones of the person holding them
and will mature when the adult dies this
also could be the game of a mechanic
with each death leading to a new life
also these babies look like some kind of
portal between dimensions but we'll
break down everything we know about
death stranding in a video coming soon
until then let me know your thoughts on
deaths trending and if you're intrigued
to plate I personally don't believe
deaths grounding will hit its deadline
of 2018 more realistically I think 2019
or maybe even 2020 let's hope I'm wrong
color stay back me or any Dreamcast
players in the house did you ever get
your hands on Shenmue growing up if
you're new to it Shenmue was one of the
first and genre-defining open-world
adventure games in history it defined
the QuickTime event and took
role-playing to another level
as an example there was an orphan kitten
you could leave to die on the roadside
or you could take care of them in pretty
much the same way you would a real cat
Shenmue had an exceptional core story
running through both titles in the
series but then it vanished luckily it's
coming back as Shenmue 3 picking up the
story of Ryo Hazuki sorry if I butchered
that name there and his search for his
father's killer it's been 16 years since
we saw Shenmue 2
and thanks to crowdfunding it's time for
a new generation to finally have closure
on the story maybe it's time to dust off
the old Dreamcast one more time and
venture into 1980s China Shenmue 3 will
be a console exclusive but he will also
be released on Windows PC to PlayStation
have many titles spanning numerous
console generations one in particular
has had a soft reboot to adapt to modern
gameplay mechanics God of War it's been
12 years since we first took control of
Kratos but this time he's bringing along
his son in this third-person
action-adventure title the game will
pick up after the events of God of War 3
and sees a much older Kratos with a damn
sexy beard I might add who has lost his
double chained blades and now possesses
a mythical battle ax which can be
infused with elemental abilities if you
like a little mythology in your video
games then god of war is for you but
this time Kratos has left behind the
Greek gods and now lives in the realm of
Norse myth so if you don't know your
Zeus from your Odin then God of War will
teach you the voice acting and dialogue
sound amazing and begin to show the
nurturing side of Kratos as he teaches
his son to hunt as I'm sure you expect
this is a single-player outing which
will last the average gamer around 25 to
30 hours with a balance of character
development and monster slaying away
from home
let's stick to the realms of nostalgia
for our next ps4 exclusive Shadow of the
Colossus unless you were around during
the ps2 generation this one may have
missed your attention but I can vouch
for its brilliance and you'll regularly
find it on many players top 10 games of
all time it's so good it's getting a HD
upgrade the premise is pretty simple
it focuses around wander a young warrior
who travels to a forbidden land but why
is he venturing so far away from home to
save a girl of course she has mono no no
she doesn't she's called mono hmm that
would be a very different game the only
way to save the girl of your dreams is
to take down 16 humongous monsters known
as colossi Shadow of the Colossus is
ultimately a puzzle game with the only
enemies you actually fight the colossi
themselves the views the vistas the
spectacle of the beasts are an absolute
joy to see and the twists in the
narrative are jaw-dropping to experience
if you didn't play the original do
yourself a favor don't file this one for
yourself avoid the internet until you've
finished it let's take a look at the
much-anticipated spider-man another
open-world extravaganza set in New York
thankfully this will not be yet another
retelling of Peter Parker gaining his
powers I don't know about you but I
cannot watch uncle Ben die again it rips
me to pieces mo this one will take place
around eight years after Peter
discovered his powers and his alter-ego
and is completely unrelated to the film
universe allowing the video game
spider-man to venture into new stories
and battle modern enemies the kingpin
will still be around for traditional
Spidey fans alongside other customary
villains but the main antagonist of this
one will be mr. negative he's kind of
like a modern version of dr. Jekyll and
mr. Hyde
but with over-the-top abilities the
barco elements keep this game feeling
fresh and vertical in a way that
Assassin's Creed can only dream of and
the combat is reminiscent of the batman
arkham games
so if fantasy or comic book games floats
your boat keep an eye out for marvel
spiderman due out in 2018 and i'm sure
you super Spidey fans have already
noticed miles
have you ever played a David cage game
Fahrenheit
heavy rain beyond two souls he
specializes in film noir esque multi
stranded and multi choice storytelling
his latest game Detroit become human is
another ps4 exclusive set for released
in the first half of 2018 in this
interactive story you take control of
androids who are sentient and operate in
the real world as almost second-class
citizens or slaves to be more dramatic
the brilliance of this type of game is
the branching system each decision you
make impacts future events and something
as Story ending as a character dying
wouldn't trigger a game over screen
instead the story continues and the
impact of that dead character continues
to affect the story hours later to show
the sheer magnitude of the branching
system check out all the permutations of
a hostage situation atop of a skyscraper
of all places
Detroit's become human isn't shying away
from approaching unpleasant subjects
either with domestic violence and even
child abuse depicted in a recent trailer
the whole game is effectively a neo noir
film so expect a great deal of heartache
and sadness to be experienced
let's look at another long-running
franchise Final Fantasy and the upcoming
Final Fantasy 7 remake let's quickly
state this this isn't a simple HD
upgrade on top of the ps1 classic this
is a retelling and modernization with
core gameplay changes the story revolves
around cloud a Shinra soldier who joins
a terrorist group to take down his
former employers the Shinra organization
who have a few secret projects you will
discover during your playthrough unlike
the original game the Final Fantasy 7
remake will utilize real-time combat
kind of like Kingdom Hearts if you
played that one but it will retain the
fundamentals of the Final Fantasy series
magic summons limit breakers to name a
few I personally hope they keep in the
ability to rename characters because
renaming cloud as Captain buttmunch will
make me smile for at least 100 hours by
the way a quick question if I may which
Final Fantasy title would you say is the
best ever please let me know in the
comments and if you haven't played Final
Fantasy then right captain buttmunch in
the comments to keep his legacy alive
what are you doing kiddo you really
gonna go through this and finally The
Last of Us part 2 I'm personally not
convinced this is coming out in 2018 but
the official word says it is so I'll
include it here the original Last of Us
was the defining title of the ps3 the
storytelling and the character
development were beyond brilliant and
the mechanics made us all feel for Joel
and Ellie in their attempt to survive
we've waited patiently for part 2 and
now it's almost here the story hasn't
officially been revealed but we've
gleaned a few bits of information from
the cast and directors we know that the
Last of Us part 2 we'll focus on hate
and vengeance this can be backed up with
the visuals we've seen so far
they're quite shocking to see with arms
being broken dead bodies laying around
covered in blood and some scenes of
torture the scavenging crafting and
gunplay mechanics from the original Last
of Us will be returning
but the question about the main
characters are unanswered will we be
filling the boots of Joel and Ellie
some people believe Joel has already
died by the time this game begins time
will tell I suppose in the meantime we
can listen to Ellie's skills on the
guitar
so there we have it 9 PlayStation
exclusive video games coming in 2018
which of these do you think will be
moved to 2019 my bets are on death
stranding and the Last of Us part 2 are
there any other exclusives I've missed
from this title please let me know them
in the comments below I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time